I like a thumbnail with this video
that's my DJ skills we are your friends
said every techno song ever so we are
your friends star Zac Efron and the 99
cent versions of the friends from
Entourage I live in the valley they're
not doing much with their lives with Zac
Efron he's good at being a DJ they're
not making the money they want to make
but one day Zac Efron meets up with West
Bentley who plays this great DJ from
Once Upon a Time has been he's
self-destructive he's an alcoholic he's
also the best part of this movie because
he's the best part of this movie this
movie did have things I liked in it
someone to talk about that for I already
touched on one of them Wes Bentley he
was the best part of the movie I thought
he played the role he was supposed to
play really well I liked him as the
damaged artist you know it's like the
obi-wan Kenobi but alcoholic he take
Zach Efron under his wing because he
sees something in this kid you know he's
always giving him pointers I like their
relationship it's kind of hostile at
times but there's a respect thing there
and then guess what wes bentley has this
girlfriend played by a holy guy this
girl's out of control she's really
attractive and then she starts moving
and dancing when she is you're like
that's one attractive female ladies and
gentleman and she was a good actress too
I thought she'd just be a pretty face to
look at but she's a pretty face to look
at who actually was a good actress in
this movies a good job the rest of the
movie is a boring wreck so let's talk
about that [ __ ] first of all his friends
I hated his friends honest to god I mean
you look at these guys and you're like
who are these douche bags for a moment
in this movie the movies trying to make
you feel conflicted you know he's
hanging out with Wes Bentley his friends
are calling him he ignores the phone
calling you're supposed to be like oh
man really kind of shut your friends out
for this guy who you're under the
dragon's wing you're not supposed to do
that bro code right broken oh you look
at his friend you're like yeah in your
life they're the thing holding you back
so go ahead and just keep on the road
you're going with wes Bentley when the
movie wants you to like his friends
you're not supposed to wish them gone
and then tragedy strikes the friends
circle and it kind of glosses over that
just keeps going you're like oh oh I
just didn't care anyway so it's fine
shoddy editing everywhere sometimes Zac
Efron's here other times he's there then
he's here then he's there this movie
feels like it was edited by about three
or four different people and directed by
about two or three people different
tones everywhere man there's a scene
where Zac Efron is tripping out on acid
or some [ __ ] and everyone starts turning
into cartoons and it's really confusing
but that's how you feel throughout the
entire movie so the cartoon scene is
only in one scene but you're left with
baffled like what's going on feeling
they even throw this story arc in this
movie that I am convinced was just left
on the cutting-room floor of the boiler
rooms like someone ripped that page out
of boiler room they were like we're not
gonna use this yet but one day we will
and after about 15 years of patience
today is that day doesn't pay off for
ship that stupid s Ark out of nowhere
just kind of feeds into the whole
premise of this movie that's just it's
just a shoddy ass mess not only that but
in true August 2015 fashion it is boring
also how many times this month have I
said the movie is boring I've lost count
at this point but this movie takes his
place on the mantle as another boring
ass movie in August 2015 we are your
friends was boring it was a shoddy movie
it was a wreck wes bentley was good Zac
Efron was good also the hot chick in
this movie was really good those three
people in the movie are good in the
movie although their arcs together lead
exactly where you think they're going to
lead and that is pretty much how I can
sum up this movie this movie is obvious
as [ __ ] you're like Wes Bentley takes
Zac Efron under his wing wes Bentley has
a super hot girlfriend Zac Efron has a
group of four how do you think this
movie's going to turn out exactly this
movie is like a really obvious and
unimpressive gift on Christmas or your
birthday or Hanukkah or whatever even
the wrapping paper isn't good though
it's like you get socks wrapped like
[ __ ] flop in your lap you're like I know
exactly what this is this is socks and
all right yeah it's socks and you're not
even gonna remember we are your friends
and t-minus one day ya already forgot
yeah you know orange is the new black
based on the August 2015 movies they
should make a show called August is the
new January - a couple of exceptions a
couple of gems is pretty much the
situation right so we are your friends
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more